♪ ♪
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT.
TRULY WE HAVE FOUND AMERICA'S
DOG.
ISN'T THAT POLITE?
A VIDEO OF BOSTON DYNAMICS
SPOT MINI ROBOT OPENING A DOOR
FOR A FRIEND.
IT'S ADORABLE.
UNLESS THAT OTHER ROBOT IS
FEMALE, THEN IT'S CLEARLY
SEXIST.
THIS IS IMPRESSIVE STUFF.
PERHAPS TOO IMPRESSIVE?
THIS TECHNOLOGY CAN GOES TWO
WAYS.
ROBOTS CAN DO GOOD, RESCUE LOVED
ONES FROM HOSTAGES AND
EARTHQUAKES WHILE ALSO INSISTING
THE INVALID.
THEY CAN REPLACE HUMANS AND
OTHER HIGH-RISK ENDEAVORS LIKE
WAR.
THEY LIKELY WON'T BE TRADITIONAL
BOTS BUT SWARMS OF INSECTLIKE
DRONES THAT COULD GET INTO
PLACES MEN CAN'T.
THE SECOND MORE DISTURBING TACT
IS A NONCONSCIOUS GOAL ORIENTED
CREATURE WITH COMPUTATION SPEED
BEYOND OUR COMPREHENSION.
ONCE UNLEASHED, WE CAN'T STOP
THEM.
IF THEIR GOAL IS TO OPENLY OPEN
A DOOR, HE MAY WANT TO OPEN ALL
DOORS AND MAY DISPENSE WITH US
TO DO SO.
NOTHING PERSONAL.
YOU ARE JUST IN THEIR WAY.
WE BECOME BARNYARD CHICKENS.
THE METAL GODS ARE MERCILESS
FARMERS.
I DIGRESS.
I WELCOME OUR ROBOT OVERLORDS.
OLD ROBOTS AND ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE CAN ONLY BE OUR
ALLIES, AS LONG AS WE GET THERE
FIRST BEFORE EVERYONE ELSE
BECAUSE THE COUNTRY THAT REACHES
SUPERIORITY IN THIS ARENA RULES
THE PLANET FOREVER.
THIS IS BIGGER THAN THE A-BOMB.
TO BE SCARED OF PROGRESS IS
NATURAL BUT THE ONLY THING MORE
FRIGHTENING IS LIVING IN THE
COUNTRY THAT COMES IN SECOND.
YOU GET MY POINT, DANA?
LET'S SAY CHINA BEATS US IN
THIS, CHINA IS THE NUMBER ONE
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD.
>> Dana: FIRST TO THE MOON.
WE NEED TO BE FIRST.
ALL THE MONEY, EVERYTHING
FOCUSED ON THIS.
I DON'T THINK WE ARE SET UP FOR
IT.
CHINA IS SPENDING TRILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
>> Greg: I AM WORRIED ABOUT
THIS.
WORRIED, WORRIED, WORRIED.
THE COUNTRY THAT DOESN'T PERFECT
THIS TECHNOLOGY MIGHT GET THERE
FIRST, CREATE DOING A CREATURE
THAT IS EVIL.
AND THEN WE ALL DIE.
>> Jesse: WHEN I SAW THE
VIDEO, THE FIRST THING I WANTED
TO DO WAS SHOOT THE DOG.
I THINK IT'S TERRIFYING.
I WOULD SHOOT IT.
I WOULD SHOOT THE WHOLE THING.
I WOULD SHOOT IT AND SHOOT IT
AND SHOOT IT AND THEN I WOULD
FEEL SAFE BECAUSE THE GUY I
SHARE AN OFFICE WITH THIS KIND
OF A TECH GEEK.
HE SAID PEOPLE CAN HACK INTO
THESE THINGS AND YOU CAN PUT
CAMERAS IN THEM.
IT CAN RECORD ALL THE THINGS
YOU'RE DOING.
I DON'T TRUST THESE THINGS.
I LIKE THEM AS A SERVANT OR A
BUTLER BUT IF THEY TURN, I SHOOT
IT.
>> Kimberly: IT IS LIKE ALEXA
WITH LEGS.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO SHOOT IT, GO
WITH CENTER MASS.
>> Greg: WHAT IS WRONG WITH
YOU PEOPLE?
>> Kimberly: YOU JUST TOLD US!
>> Greg: NO, NO, NO.
ROBOTS, YOU'RE LOOKING AT THIS
SHOW, REMEMBER I DEFENDED YOU.
COME FOR ME LAST.
>> Kimberly: I AM COMING FOR
YOU FIRST.
>> Greg: THERE'S GOING TO BE
ALL KINDS OF LITIGATION WITH
THESE THINGS.
THAT GUY OPENS THE DOOR, MIGHT
SLAM IT ON SOMEBODY'S FACE.
CREATES A WHOLE NEW LEGAL
SYSTEM.
>> Juan: TO ME THAT'S A
SECONDARY ISSUE.
THE PRIMARY ISSUE IS WHAT YOU
JUST DESCRIBED WHICH IS THEY ARE
OPENING DOORS AND DOING THINGS
AND THEY'VE GOT CAMERAS IN THEM.
ELON MUSK SAYS WE'VE GOT TO
MERGE WITH THEM.
INSTEAD OF WORRYING ABOUT THEM
TAKING OVER, WE'VE GOT TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO WORK WITH THEM OR
BECOME ONE WITH THEM.
>> Jesse: WE WILL NEVER GET
THROUGH SECURITY AT THE AIRPORT.
>> Juan: THEY WOULD KNOW WHO
YOU ARE.
>> Greg: LOOK AT THIS THE WAY
WE EVOLVE FROM PRIMITIVE MAN.
THIS IS THE NEXT EVOLUTION.
WE ARE NEANDERTHAL COMPARED TO
THIS.
WE MIGHT AS WELL GET USED TO IT.
I DON'T THINK YOU CAN MELD A
MACHINE WITH MAN.
YOU ARE ALREADY MELTING IT WITH
YOUR PHONE.